so here we are
my first stop on my long journey
travelled thousands of miles to be here
I love it here
I miss this place so much it's been 25
years since I've been here and you know
I hope you really enjoy hanging out with
me today
Casa villa home is gonna hang out with
us - he's right there
come on let's have some fun I'm so happy
to be here
Copland says lies dear to my heart you
know I spent a lot of time here walking
along with my family along the Rhine
along the summer I think it's really
cool of the German government to put the
statue there because when I was here the
camera it was just a canopy look at this
this is the top of the world you know
what I like about here you know where
the Rhine and Mosel meet from this
distance from this height you can see
exactly where where they you know where
the water kind of splits
it's Wow even on a dreary day like this
it's so beautiful
look how beautiful this churches I mean
that's not the nice thing about
Copeland's there's so many churches
this place is so intricate each house
has like little charming statues on it
and the ironwork it's really beautiful
it's uh you know it's bringing back a
lot of memories so I haven't seen you
know you surely don't see this in
America
so when I was a kid what my mother did
so that to keep my brother and me happy
well busy she put us in this thing
called kinder heart and I'm not quite
sure but I think it's there it is that's
the Kindle heart the skate was in here
we're coming through here
there you are little Schengen show you
little mischievous little boy are you
still spitting at people when I was
living here in the 80s in the summertime
he would just be a steady stream and
this is also I almost as famous as the
start just act this is a cold-blooded
shingle show
hey I know Coleman says famous for their
wine so I just had to visit one of the
famous wineries like come on join me
I'm sure you will like it you will love
it I'm here with a real a real vintner
this is like being in a different world
it's like being a different time so this
is the barrier cave for the red wine so
here we have the Pinot Noir a la that's
delicious
now I know why Copeland's is so famous
for their wines this is great I hope you
had as much fun as I've had on this
great Dame's great trip Cheers